[Music]
[Applause]
let me get to Rick neisel the former
coach and he was working for CBS SEC
title game and uh kind enough to join us
all right Rick when you went to bed
Saturday night what did you think was
going to happen with the committee on
Sunday I thought exactly what transpired
would transpire I had it right I said it
on the uh end of our broadcast at the
SEC game that I I envisioned Louisville
winning the game because the third
string quarterback would play for
Florida State congratulations Florida
State's defense for playing so
brilliantly uh but I did think that the
sec's champion would find a way in and
by means that Alabama was in that role
they'd bring Texas with them why did
Florida State get left
out first of all it's crushing for all
of us who coach knowing what Mike
norvell's going through uh I saw his
face as he got the news on that screen
and it was I mean devastating can only
imagine because what else do you do
other than win all your games uh
but the it's there's the SEC and the Big
10 I I think Washington Dan should be
the number one team I mean Washington's
in the better conference this year the
Pack 12 is a better conference they beat
Oregon twice Michigan has the Ohio State
victory who's already jettison their
quarterback I mean Michigan's victories
Iowa was 133rd in offense Michigan state
was 128 in offense Minnesota was 125th
ruter was 123rd Nebraska was 118 Indiana
was 101st East Carolina was 130th and
Bowling Green was 105th that's their
schedule and what and they had 1.9 yards
per carry against Iowa less than five
yards an
attemp against Iowa I michig Washington
should be one and so here's here's my
point my point is the Big 10 and the SEC
are always going to get in because they
moved the needle television wise it's
nothing that's dis it's discussed in the
in the uh meeting room I don't think
anybody sits there well these two are in
but they're in they have to be in
because they can take their ball and go
home I was with Larry Scott when the
college football playoff was discussed
and it was adamant amongst many of the
Commissioners that the four teams had to
all be Conference champions yeah Mike S
said no and he was going to say I'm not
in if we don't do it this way and he
wielded that kind of bat and I don't say
it because he's bad he had that kind of
influence and he was taking care of his
conference so Michigan as the Big 10
champ has to be where they are and
Alabama as the SEC champ has to be in
and by virtue of Texas's victory over
Alabama they're in as well I would tell
you if Georgia would have won that game
it would have been Texas out Florida
state would have been in I truly believe
that okay does Georgia have a gripe of
not being in the final four sure but
there's just no room at the end this
time I mean they can't get in over
Alabama and they can't get in because
Texas beat Alabama it just there is no
room yeah uh and it this is just one of
those weird years where we've got uh so
many really really Talent teams at the
top I wonder maybe it's conspiracy
theory that the playoff committee goes
uh yeah Michigan you're in signs
stealing Scandal your reward is you get
Alabama maybe so maybe so because again
I I thought that uh Michigan should have
been behind Washington now the only
thing the only metric that they can say
Washington's behind Michigan is you know
game control Michigan pounded uh lesser
opponents and I just went through that
resume list uh by the way have you ever
heard of a team going into a game where
they over under of the first half Point
tattle is one
half the the new fight song at illino at
Iowa is how low can you go the limbo
song it's it's incredible I know but uh
I I I do believe that uh I the team that
would surprise me most winning at all
would be
Michigan why I I think Alabama because
they're the least explosive team of all
of them the other three teams have the
ability to put up points and make big
plays I don't know that Michigan has
that same kind of skill we're talking to
Rick neis former college coach works for
CBS Sports will we ever have this level
of drama in the playoffs
again uh I don't know that this level of
drama will exist when we get to 1213
conversation you know because be
assuming the Champions coming four to
five to six so uh I don't know that
we'll get to this so if there's a way to
go out with drama as uh with the
exclamation point this is probably it I
think you could go back to when Auburn
got screwed when we had you know oh yeah
BCS yeah when they went undated so we
had without question three teams
undefeated and and then they got left
out and then that felt like that kick
started well we got to have four teams
in
and now we go to 12 and how long do we
stay at 12 in your
opinion great question it will deter it
will be determined by if we consolidate
and and and bring down division one to
that kind of NFLs 48 to 64 teams it will
deter be determined by that if we go to
that I would say that we'll eventually
be at
16 who are you voting for for the
Heisman uh Jaden Daniels he's he's been
Sensational I had thought I had said
that the winner of that pack 12 matchup
if the quarterbacks are as advertised
and I thought pennx was brilliant if
he'd had four touchdown passes rather
than one just so the numbers for the
voters would have been bigger I think
penck would have had a fighting chance
but that was a uh that's been a
brilliant run for kayin D'Or at watching
Washington is there anything more
dangerous than Nick Sabin in the
playoffs in college football nothing no
nothing yeah he delivered you know I'm
from the church of
Sabin and and uh Hallelujah you know uh
he delivered a perfect sermon on on
Saturday I mean the guy is just
Sensational he's Sensational and and the
Jaylen Milow story boy is one for the
ages but you know what's interesting
Rick and I mentioned this earlier that
he was in a spread offense when he was
in high school he didn't run right
that's right and and he's learning damn
I'm as fast if not faster than these
guys I'm going you could almost see it
in his eyes that now he understands I'm
told that because he's a neopit now I
don't think much is innate in terms of
his instincts for the game but he's so
uniquely talented as he continues to
evolve I'm told that he does not have a
uh option mentality they tell him to
give it or to keep it on these
particular plays when he evolves and he
can read the defender and he takes it
when he when it's appropriate to take it
Katie bar the door he is going to be a
sensation I said at the beginning of the
game I took Alabama and I said because
milrose legs now milrose legs weren't a
factor in the game but you could see
what they did to George's pass rush they
were sitting there with the spy and they
were letting him back there count the
house now they got to him a few times
because somebody would get off of that
block But ultimately at the end of the
game where they needed first downs a 30
yard run and a n yard run where the
difference that guy is special yeah if
the QB C mcord is uh going to enter the
portal with Ohio state does that mean
they're in the market outside of Ohio
State for they are they jettisoned them
that that has to be the case yes you
don't leave Ohio State there's no
there's no Greener pasture especially
given the receivers that they have
accumulated there that's been that was a
uh you need to look for someplace else
if Quinn yers returns to
Texas you know that one kid that is
above the transfer portal Madness won't
get swayed by you know wanting to play
the musical chairs game it would be Arch
Manning he won't get involved in all
that so Quinn ERS I would fully expect
to come back and play again at Texas who
wouldn't want to be the quarterback on
the 40 acres right given all the you
know fancy uh bells and whistles that go
with that job uh they're in the playoff
for the first time by the way
congratulations to Sark it's the first
time he's ever won 10 games it's the
first conference Champion he's ever had
so uh wonderful job by him and they
might be the fastest team in America
Texas might be the fastest team
according and you put those two
beautiful defensive tackles in that uh
in that in that shiny window I'm in New
York right now you know how they put all
those holiday treats in the window you
put dandre sweat and Byron Murphy in
there the uh college football coaches
would be sitting out there longing let
me go back to Arch Manning he wants to
play yeah okay it's not about nil this
is about opportunity you could go to USC
right now you could go to Ohio State
right now many others with Archie with
pton with Eli and Cooper patience will
win the day okay I think patience will
win the day he's different because he
can be different good to talk to you bud
thanks for joining us always a pleasure
happy holidays my friend Rick
neisel always good
always enlightens us